there's a lot of pretty awesome stuff
here at Star Wars Celebration Rob
definitely got your remote control r2
d2's right baby Ewoks families of
stormtroopers giant rancor named Roxy oh
she's adorable entire Mos Eisley cantina
oh yeah all sorts of rides rides things
yet right on anyways we're here to talk
about star wars battlefront cuz come on
battlefront they showed it off to us
behind closed doors got to take a look
at not only the trailer but also an
extended gameplay demo and let's start
right from the start this is on the
forest moon of Endor right it's your
among the huge trees and the immediate
thing that's striking about it is the
foliage is the environment that detail
it looks incredible it's really good
yeah like right off the bat you're kind
of walking around with your squad of
rebel fighters and what really
captivated me was there didn't seem to
be like a distinguishable path right
like they just kind of venture off into
the woods you right off the bat it does
feel like you're on a scouting mission
and you sort of encounter the fringes of
a battle alone imperial scout and then
room like the speeder bike cruises by
with one of your buddies in chase and it
slowly sort of opens up from there of
course this is a very scripted demo you
know it's the first look at the game but
what we saw was looks pretty cool so
you've got the battlefront stuff of you
know you can switch between first-person
and third-person at any point the mode
we saw was Walker battle the biggest
mode they have at 40 players the
smallest mode they have eight players
they didn't go into much more detail
about that but there were some walkers
we saw some 80's teas right and then the
8080 it's not really clear but it's kind
of hinted that it's going to be like a
powerup kind of item essentially maybe
like a progression type thing where you
know you get a throw down shield that
you can use and then the next
maybe in a TST the next with envy maybe
an 80 80 looks like the ultimate
actually it's not the ultimate what's
hinted at the ultimate power up is going
to be your hero or villain in the demo
case it was Darth Vader himself as Darth
Vader rocking the force choke of course
the deflecting lasers and then slaying
the the rebel Scouts that you were
playing as but yet like in previous
battlefront games those sort of rewards
of you know hero characters come in here
like big vehicles coming down the pipe
to help change the tide of battle help
escalate things as the fight goes on
another thing they brought up was a
partner system type of feature where
essentially you can kind of tag team
with a buddy team up with him no matter
what your level is whatever you unlock I
get as far as unlockables go yeah you're
going to be able to share your kit with
your partner and how exactly whether
that's a loadout screen thing or an in
battle look here take my rocket launcher
shooting gun thing is a little unclear
but the partner system is basically that
squad mechanic from battlefield only
paired way down so you can spawn on your
partner you can see where they are on
the map at all times it's encouraging
you to team up and stay with them and I
think some of the kit is also going to
be geared towards partner play we saw an
area dome shield we saw personal dome
shields we saw power weapons like sniper
rifles and rocket launchers we saw
regular weapons like blasters and
grenades all play out in this conflict
and here's the thing though there's no
classes so any of the stuff you unlock
you can mix and match and put it into
your character as you folks no doubt saw
in the trailer you're also going to be
able to play as non-human characters
aliens of other races whether or not
those were hero characters specifically
shown or not a little unclear from
trailer I'm gonna have to wait to hear
more about that yeah but you can expect
yeah Darth Vader I'm sure Luke Skywalker
what was also hinted is that you will be
able to take on roles kind of surly a
infantry person but more like a
millennium falcon in a air combat
van Orson oh absolutely i mean the
trailer showed it we didn't get to see
any demos of sort of air combat in
action but yeah certainly tons of TIE
fighters next wings dueling it out we
see maybe some flying low so there's
sort of like that interplay between air
and ground combat and no doubt there's
going to be well we don't know if
they're going to be space battles
all-out battle front two where you can
sort of pop into the bigger land and
like hop out of your vehicle and hop in
they definitely had all the classics on
display and not much more than that at
this point this course is still our
first look was running on pre alpha on
PlayStation 4 very classic battlefront
so far and looking very good also worth
noting that though battlefront very much
a multiplayer-focused game you're also
going to be able to play it solo and
co-op and then they also brought up the
tie in with the movie itself sure which
is called battle of jakku yeah it's a
DLC map that's going to come out a
couple weeks after the launch battle
star wars battlefront is launching on
november seventeenth and then on
december eight free for everybody on all
on all platforms battle of jakku a big
conflict at the beginning of the
features heavily in the force awakens
was of course coming out in December
around Christmas time you're going to
get be able to get that map a week early
if you preorder but egg everyone gets it
free on December 8th that was the only
sort of tease they made towards the
content that's going to overlap with
force awaken clearly still a lot to be
seen for battlefront a lot of questions
I'm going to get into that in our
written preview which you can check out
on the site but for now from Star Wars
Celebration battlefront looking pretty
good looking pretty good
I